[Musique]
1713 le 27 février 1713 Louis XIV signe
une ordonnance pour interdire la chasse
des tortues sur l'île Bourbon cela ne
fait que 50 ans que le peuplement de
lîle a commencé mais un peu plus de 1000
habitants et pourtant certaines espèces
animales sont déjà en danger
d'extinction ainsi s'il n'y a jamais eu
de dodo à la Réunion le solitaire avec
lequel on l'a confondu avait déjà
disparu les habitants se livrent à un
massacre de la faune parmi laquelle on
trouve les tortues marines et terrestres
qui attiraient déjà la convoitise des
marin de
passage à partir de 1700 il n'y a plus
qu'à Saint-Leu où les colons commencent
à s'installer que l'on trouve encore des
tortues 70 ans plus tard elles ont
disparu du littoral réignonnais en 1977
la Réunion ouvre la ferme coraille à
Saint-Leu pour élever des tortues
récupérées aux îles épars mais il s'agit
de les exploiter en vendant cher et
écaille alors que l'espèce est menacée
d'extinction
mondiale depuis 2006 cette exploitation
a été remplacée par l'Observatoire
Kelonia qui soigne protège réintroduit
la Tortue dans son milieu naturel et
apprend aux jeunes réunionné à la
respecter d'ailleurs aviez-vous remarqué
que la carte de notre île peut se
dessiner sous le signe de la tortue 1713
ordonnance contre l'extermination des
tortues de
[Musique]
mer